super der spa nicht wahr ja super mega
also wenn es jetzt nicht schafft dann
rede von span span font super hole
ja liebe ich versuche hier heute in
rheinland pfalz ein bisschen die leute
in richtung jens sparen zu mobilisieren
indem ich die anderen beiden schlecht
mache was kann man schlechtes über märz
und kramp karrenbauer sagen könnte
schlecht über mehr zu sagen dass er ein
buntes den sie zynisch dass er auf
seinem auto den aufkleber hat ich bremse
auch für die untere mittelschicht
das ist schon recht sicher aber
irgendwie ja auch geil oder zynisch
einfach nur irgendwie auch kein geld ist
geil macht ich geil ich habe gehört
hatten vermögen von 750 millionen liegen
gehören anteile haben
er ist immerhin der
verwaltungsratsvorsitzende von von
bleckede
vielleicht folgt stellung die wollen
jetzt ja anteil des weltalls versteigern
wie finden sie daran
wir sind doch dinge die nie realisiert
werden mechanisch und werden eher so
clever ist und als anwalt und hat sich
da ein zweites standbein oder einige
andere standbeine geschaffen
jeder ist das drücke schmid und wenn
jemand so viel geld verdient hat als
auch verdient und die ihr favorit ist
merz obwohl ich gehört habe dass er die
ersten drei jahre seines lebens als
mädchen groß gezogen wurde
daran ändert sich darf beim für mich ein
statiker hatte da immer mädchen
klamotten an
er wurde als kleine nonne verkleidet
finden sie das nicht ein bisschen
seltsam
ja aber da kann er ja selber als mensch
nichts dafür wie finden sie ist es mit
friedrich merz wirtschafts vergangenheit
kann man das gutheißen
also eine vergangenheit ist immer gut zu
haben sonst wäre man dem baby sonst hat
man keine zukunft wirklich ist das so
weil wenn man gar keine vergangenheit
hat man ja eigentlich nur zukunft die
cdu ist eben eine zukunfts verteilen
deswegen ist auch platz für leute mit
vergangenheit was denken sie wer von den
dreien wird das rennen machen
annegret kramp karrenbauer ja ich bin ja
hier um für jens spahn ein bisschen
wahlkampf zu machen
auch ein guter aber annegret kramp
karrenbauer annette kam keiner herum
bauern frau kompakt
es ist ein total schwieriger name wir
können einfach rkk sagt ich habe gehört
dass sie 1975 bis 1978 verbot hatte in
ihrem schwimmbad wo sie aufgewachsen
mädchen vom zehnmeterbrett geschubst hat
wie finden sie das
das ist eine komische geschichte aber
kramp karrenbauer die hat an gewicht
gesunde augen trägt aber kontaktlinsen
damit seine brille braucht einfach um
schlaue auszusehen das ist doch nicht
normal
na ja dass ich jeden und seine eigene
sache das ist eine echte brille brauchen
sie die wir hatten keine brille
das finde ich authentisch ihr mittlerer
sohn ist ja saarländischer meister im
pokémon go wie finden sie das
klasse finden sie das nicht komisch wenn
der so viel am handy im warum dabbelt
das ist ein sport das können wir
vielleicht in unserer altersklasse mich
direkt zu sehen aber ist tatsächlich ein
sport mit mir spricht geld
jens spahn zum volk
[Musik]
die andern sind
ja
sparen ist so ein siegertyp
euren sind lang
denn sparen sparen er sprach alles für
sie gegeben
darf ich kurz zu herrn sparen wir sind
quasi freunde ich habe so für sie
gefeuert
[Musik]
jetzt sparen das war klasse ich habe
alles gegeben damit die leute sie wählen
wenn es jetzt nicht klappt dann liegt es
an hin und damit zurück ins studio
[Musik]